- I'm like, why am I giving
birth to the green goblin?
- For Halloween this year,
Burger king has decided to
make a Whopper with a black bun
and we're here today to try it out.
- I've heard that the Halloween Whopper
makes your poop turn green.
- Part of being young
and you know, having fun.
It's just eating things and seeing
what they do to your poop.
- I'm gonna unwrap this.
- Look at that.
- Oh there she is.
- This is like, dark.
This is obsidian as (beep).
- It looks like they took a hockey puck
and cut it in half, and then
stuck sesame seeds on it.
- It's smells like a normal cheeseburger.
Just, I don't know, it's black,
it's weird.
It looks like it's rotten
but it feels alright.
- Here we go.
- It's fine, it's not like amazing,
it's not terrible.
- Tastes like a cheeseburger.
- I feel like it kinda like enhances
their whole char broiled thing.
- It tastes a little odd,
it tastes like there's some weird,
there's something weird going on here.
- Big fan right here,
this is good stuff.
- Burger King, is this a ploy
to get more black people
to come to your restaurant?
Okay.
- The green poop aspect definitely made me
wanna try this more
because I'm a sick weirdo.
- I am not so nervous about
how it's gonna come out,
I'm actually kind of excited to see.
- I'm kinda concerned about
my poop turning green,
but that's a future me problem
so we'll get there when that happens.
- Woke up this morning,
went to my bathroom, sat down,
did my business, and it was very green.
Like highlighter green.
- The poop happened.
- My poop was green.
- It's such an unnatural color,
it like looks like a joke.
- I would say it was kind of like
an olive green bordering on emerald.
- I think it was like
underwhelming a little bit.
- It's literally this color.
- I think life would be better not only
if everyone pooped green,
but if people pooped
different colors based on what they ate.
- I would definitely eat it again.
- That was this morning, so we'll see
what this afternoon and
this evening has in for me.